[Musica]
viralità capacità di diffondersi in modo
particolarmente veloce e capillare
utilizzando i new media
ciò che è virale ci piace costituisce un
trend ci incuriosisce ci ispira ma non
solo viralità è il punto di unione che
intercorre tra due fenomeni devianti e
criminali che si stanno diffondendo nel
web il revenge porn ed il cyberbullismo
il fenomeno conosciuto come il reverse
porn in cui vi è una diffusione illecita
di materiale a contenuto sessualmente
esplicito senza il consenso della
vittima ritratta è oggi un reato e la
norma pone l'accento tanto
sull'importanza a quanto sul peso lesivo
della viralità prevedendo una pena
massima di sei anni di reclusione
tanto per chi produce e immette per la
prima volta questo materiale in internet
tanto per chi lo riceve e si preoccupa
di inviarlo e diffonderlo e così
centinaia e migliaia di video a
contenuto sessualmente esplicito
circolano ogni giorno su siti forum
gruppi come nel caso telegram di aprile
lo conoscete tutti telegram no
in questi gruppi che raggiungevano
migliaia di iscritti venivano condivise
foto e video sessualmente espliciti
ritraenti fidanzate ex fidanzate mogli
ed ex moglie ma non solo anche foto e
video autoprodotti da genitori
molestatori che sceglievano di
condividere l'intimità dei propri figli
minorenni
i contenuti una volta invece in internet
diventano incontrollabili l'intimità
delle vittime violata
i loro corpi virtualmente violentati ad
ogni ricondivisione ed eccoci di fronte
a quella che potremmo definire la nuova
frontiera della violenza sessuale quella
online perché l'un l'altro è come
definito da vari autori se non un abuso
sessuale è basato sull'immagine un cyber
stupro provate per un attimo a pensare
se succedesse a voi se delle foto dei
video realizzati ad esempio in intimità
o per gioco diventassero virali se
questi fossero ovunque
tutto questo è dovuto in gran parte a
una colpa collettiva alla costante
proposta di immagini sessualizzati
oggettivi cate cosa comportano portano i
potenziali autori di raven sporn a
pensare al corpo in particolar modo a
quello femminile come ad un oggetto di
intrattenimento sessuale ma non solo
portano le vittime le donne ad auto
oggettificazione vincersi che l'essere
attraenti e apprezzate sia possibile
solo se coincidente con l'essere sexy e
provocanti è capitato a tutti di
vestirci in maniera sexy e provocante
per compiacere qualcuno
ed è così però che le giovani donne poco
in essere dei comportamenti sempre
sicure del fatto che ci sia un legame di
fiducia col proprio partner legame che
però ben presto verrà violato la chat
che noi abbiamo definito essere il nuovo
spazio affettivo ed emotivo diviene
sempre più spesso il luogo in cui sicuri
del dell'anonimato e mossi dall effetto
disinibente del web gli utenti si
abbandonano sempre più spesso a condotte
imprudenti opportunità questa che gli
autori di reato non si lasciano certo
sfuggire
e la utilizzano a loro favore ed è così
che la vittima lesa nella propria
intimità venduta e ceduta all'intera
platea virtuale diviene la poco di buono
la stupida che se l'è cercata
e non importa che si sia diffuso un
contenuto privato il fatto che quel
contenuto sia autoprodotto rende le
vittime meritevoli di essere umiliate e
denigrate e gli autori di reato
addosseranno tutta la colpa alla vittima
sostenuti da un pubblico di cyber
spettatori giudicanti che sosterranno la
prevaricazione
la cosa più sconcertante che abbiamo
notato è che spesso questi sarebbe
spettatori giudica anche erano altre
donne
una volta una persona mi ha detto che il
motivo per cui le donne spesso non siamo
dove dovremmo essere perché non
riusciamo a collaborare ed è vero
dovremmo spalleggiarsi di più io e
roberto ad esempio le cose più belle che
abbiamo fatto insieme
ma torniamo alla viralità che il nostro
fulcro centrale tanto nei rilanci porno
quanto nel cyber bullismo un fenomeno
dalle mille condotte quali azioni ostili
e intenzionali operate attraverso
strumenti elettronici con il
cyberbullismo gli atti prevaricatori che
erano contenuti precedentemente
soprattutto all'interno della dimensione
scolastica prendono forme diverse
vengono appunto operate nel web ad
esempio sotto forma di commenti ostili e
violenti verso il prossimo che spesso
neanche si conosce è proprio così che le
vittime di questi reati si sentiranno in
gabbia perché a quel punto chiunque
potrà vedere il contenuto denigratorio e
condividerlo con un numero indefinito di
spettatori bulli zanti violenti e
giudicanti
tale condizione porta le vittime a
pensare che non vi sia via d'uscita e
che l'unica via sia quella estrema
quella del suicidio come è successo a
tiziana cantone e a carolina picchio
tutti potremmo essere vittime di
bullismo e cyberbullismo anche noi in
questo momento perché magari emozionate
e chi siamo emozionati troppo magari
dimentichiamo la parola oppure sbagliamo
un verbo no e veniamo ridicolizzate
ma accettare le proprie fragilità e
comunicarle in qualche modo anticipa il
nemico no lo disarma ebbene tutto questo
aumento esponenziale di odio di ostilità
online è attribuibile alla continua
ricerca soprattutto da parte delle nuove
generazioni a voler provare emozioni
forti per riempire quella noia cronica
che li pervade chievo che appunto quelle
fragilità personali come in una sorta di
esorcismo mediatico per alleggerire gli
stenti negativi e le frustrazioni e
quello che accade un po partecipando
anche alle challenge su tik tok come ad
esempio la pena del challenge che ha
visto purtroppo recentemente la morte di
una giovane ragazza americana per
overdose il caso telegram di cui
parlavamo prima ne è un altro esempio sì
perché oltre a una diffusione di
materiale illecito
vi è una sconcertante richiesta di
contenuti violenti stupri di gruppo
vessazioni e questo ci deve dare un pò
la giusta dimensione del livello di
normalizzazione della violenza e della
pornografia a cui siamo arrivati e nel
nel momento che abbiamo vissuto a causa
dell'emergenza sanitaria nel momento di
cattività che abbiamo vissuto tutto
questo si è amplificato l'uso del
dispositivo ve ne sarete accorti è
diventato un antistress uno strumento
utilizzato per alleggerire le proprie
tensioni personali
ma lì tutto questo però spesso a
discapito delle vittime
possiamo fare anche l'esempio delle
numerose dirette aperte in vari social
che spesso si sono trasformate in vere e
proprie stanze della rabbia delle red
room 2.0 in cui chiunque poteva farvi
ingresso e inveire brutalmente ed
indistintamente contro l'altro senza
neanche più servirsi dell'anonimato
ma scegliere di farlo a faccia scoperta
e possiamo dire che anche l'odio quindi
ha subito un profondo cambiamento
attentare alla reputazione altrui
diviene più importante che salvaguardare
la propria e quindi non più odiare
qualcuno o qualcosa ma odiare e basta sì
diciamo che a questo punto ci siamo
chieste ma a cosa porta tutto questo
tutto questo altera la percezione delle
proprie condotte online ma soprattutto
altera la percezione del danno arrecato
alla vittima che viene da umanizzata e
ridotta un'entità digitale la de
umanizzazione peraltro non è mai stata
così facile in internet con la perdita
della dimensione face to face la
conseguente smaterializzazione dei
rapporti di viene pericolosamente
semplice ma i danni sono reali reali
tanto quanto sono reali le vittime e
soprattutto non si esauriscono
nell'ambiente digitale ma possono avere
conseguenze irreparabili come quelle che
abbiamo visto e quindi sensibilizzare
per noi significa farlo sotto tutti i
punti di vista
sensibilizzare significa informare
genitori sulla pericolosità di internet
sensibilizzare significa parlare alle
vittime per potenziare la loro autostima
e la loro auto consapevolezza
sensibilizzare significa certamente
parlare agli autori di reato
risvegliando in qualche modo la loro
capacità empatica perché comprendano le
emozioni altrui e non diventino degli
analfabeti emotivi e sensibilizzare
significa ancora parlare a tutti quegli
spettatori silenziosi che tacciono
come se l'odio e la violenza ormai
fossero fisiologici del web
e infatti non sono più soltanto gli
autori di reato che subiscono una
alterazione della percezione ma anche
gli spettatori
i cyber spettatori spettatori che
subiscono una smaterializzazione dei
rapporti online spogliati dalla loro
componente fisica immediati da l'uso del
dispositivo vengono investiti da quello
che potremmo definire un vero e proprio
alleggerimento emotivo con una perdita
progressiva e costante di empatia nei
confronti dell'altro
anche i soggetti che acquisiscono il la
figura il ruolo di spettatori passivi e
che quindi non si schierano né a favore
né contro la vittima acquisiscono il
ruolo di connivente cioè colui il quale
assiste ad un reato e sceglie di non
interromperlo
è questo questo atteggiamento provoca un
enorme ostacolo perché tutto questo sarà
sempre percepito come normale e quindi
ci saranno sempre più utenti che
porranno in essere delle condotte non
consapevoli del fatto che tutto questo
non è assolutamente normale e questo fa
sì che viene diffusa la responsabilità
su tutti gli utenti e quindi in capo ad
un utente
ci sarà una piccola porzione di colpa e
così sarà alleggerito il loro senso di
auto condanna e avranno una ridotta
capacità ad auto percepirsi come
devianti e come criminali e george angel
tema per cui siamo tutti qui questa sera
lo sappiamo
il cambiamento va verso la
digitalizzazione ma è bene ricordare che
competenza informatica non è sinonimo di
consapevolezza informatica e che quindi
essere competenti rispetto all'uso dei
dispositivi informatici non significa
automaticamente essere competenti
rispetto ai rischi che tale utilizzo
nasconde e quindi è per questo che ci
stiamo impegnando ancora una volta
insieme per fare dei progetti nelle
scuole per sensibilizzare i ragazzi ad
un uso consapevole del web e soprattutto
per formarli ed informarli sui rischi
derivanti anche dalle loro stesse
condotte imprudenti e sulle alterazioni
percettive dei reati subiti e commessi
in rete ma soprattutto per prevenire
stimolando il potenziamento delle loro
capacità emotive e relazionali
speriamo di riuscirci grazie a tratti
[Applauso]